The king is dead
I can't be king
know who you are or what you seek the door
remains shut until we finish our business
it is treason at the least I found
out something you should know
have you never imagined yourself on the iron throne
Welcome
back everyone it's Charlie this will be my house
of the Dragon episode 9 trailer video there's
a whole bunch of Easter eggs and references so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to the
channel I'll be doing videos for all the episodes
just like I did for the original Game of Thrones
series be sure to subscribe to get them careful
for spoilers from episode 8 if you haven't seen it
yet because we have to talk about that to explain
what's happening during episode nine but the king
is dead long live the king so King viserys died
at the end of episode 8 so this is the aftermath
immediately after the events of his death at the
beginning of the trailer it seems like they start
with the iron throne in the middle of the night
and it's been right after his death alicent just
left him and she says she understood what he was
telling her to do she mistakenly believed that
he was telling her that aegon II should be king
naming him successor and unite the realm otherwise
terrible things would happen so because she's so
hardcore about Duty about doing what people ask
her to do especially people in power like the king
himself she did her Duty laying underneath him for
years and years and years even though it sounds
like initially she never wanted to marry him in
the first place but it was was her duty to do so
so it sounds like she believes something terrible
might wind up happening if she doesn't make aegon
the second the next king it's not a thing where
she wants power for herself or she wants the iron
throne for herself even though princess rhaenys
is whispering in her ear telling her that have
you never imagined yourself on the iron throne
and I think she'll have a similar reaction to
what we saw during episode 8 from her at the
head of the small Council she seemed a little
annoyed with her father in vaman for trying to
play The Game of Thrones so to speak like they
were very clearly trying to form an agreement with
each other like you name me air of driftmark and
he'll make it a much more profitable arrangement
for the throne you see Alison also at the head
of the small Council again but it still seems
like it's early in the morning like they just
learned about his death because I don't think
that alicent thought that he died after she
left him someone properly discovered in the wee
hours of the morning when they went to check on
him so like a couple hours may have gone by she
seems very crestfallen but you see Kristen Cole
and her father standing next to her very important
because they're like the most Hardcore team green
at the moment you see one of the the King's
Guard sharpening his sword that just imply
everything that they do during the trailer here
like they basically lock all the blacks in their
rooms to prevent any kind of struggle when they
try to put aegon on the Iron Throne like they
want to crown him and they want to pull this off
before team black can get to their dragons or do
anything this might have something to do with
the air being named and everybody just going a
little bit crazy hearing that the King has died
it's not totally clear what aemond is doing this
is much later in the day when the other Lords the
rest of court has found out what has happened and
Otto Hightower is basically telling them the
wishes of the king is for aegon II to be named
King he's basically forcing all the ones who
are here to swear fealty to aegon II which is
sort of like a dark mirror for episode one when
everybody swore fealty to renera as the heir this
shot of Amen with the kingsguard and someone
sitting in foreground here all blurry is aegon
II wearing aegon the conqueror's crown so they
actually pull out aegon the conqueror's crown to
do this remember it's Valyrian steel it's the only
crown that's valyrian steal they basically had it
in storage ever since maegor died maegor was like
the next person after aegon the conqueror to wear
it when aegon the conqueror's son anes became
King he wore a different crown and so different
people wear different crowns just based on their
personal preference or based on the context so for
instance King jaeherys had like a small rebellion
against King maegor and when he became King when
he was a young child he wore a different crown
because the realm had just sat under this really
terrible person who had been wearing aegon's crown
so that's why he wanted to wear a different crown
it when viserys became king he just continued
wearing jaeherys' crown. So the whole issue in
this mad rush of the greens to put aegon on the
iron throne and crown him in the blacks trying
to figure out what's going on and get free is what
winds up happening to the actual physical crowns
themselves and it sounds like rhaenyra winds up
getting away with her father viserys's crown and
that's why the greens use aegon the conqueror's
crown to put on aegon II because otherwise they
would have just put viserys's crown on his head
you also remember that right now in the timeline
just based on the changes during this recent time
jump, Aemond seems like a big wild card he's sort
of like the flip side of Daemon it seems like
they're developing him as more of a rival for
Daemon than the younger characters like you would
expect he even looks kind of like Daemon in fact
when the first trailer initially dropped last year
people confused him for Daemon like oh why is Matt
Smith wearing an eye patch and if you think about
it aemond is just an anagram of Daemon so I think
they just want to present them like flip sides
of two coin like aemond is a little more chaotic
than Daemon has become in his old age like Daemon
used to be a little bit more like that but he's
kind of chilled out in his old age they're kind
of building a big conflict between the two of
them that they'll play out during the actual
dance of the dragons in later seasons like a
much bigger fight between the two of them it's
kind of like Ned Stark vs Jaime Lannister in
the first couple of episodes of Game of Thrones
where Ned Stark basically told Jaime that I don't
want to show someone what I'm capable of in case
there actually is a fight and they never wound up
paying off that fight like Jaime Lannister kept
challenging him this time though we'll actually
get to see a version of Daemon fighting aemond
when Otto Hightower is talking to the kingsguard
here telling him you have to be secret it nobody
can know who you are what you're trying to find I
think it's him trying to find viserys's Crown
you see all the blacks locked in their rooms
rhaenyra everybody just trying to figure out
what's going on like why have you locked us in
our chambers why won't you let us leave news of
the King's death also probably spreads pretty
fast around the castle so even though they do get
locked in their rooms they probably find out what
has happened pretty quickly these are just the
regular Palace guards you see the woman here who
was working for Mysteria and also knew about what
happened with aegon's bastard there's also a very
Targaryen looking small child that seems like it's
been living in flea bottom which might be one of
the bastards of one of these characters that might
be what Aemond is doing in flea bottom like going
to kill all the bastards the same way that Joffrey
did the same thing when he was getting ready to be
named King on the orders of Joffrey the kingsguard
and the city watch basically went around killing
all of Robert's bastards that they could find
obviously they didn't know about Gendry at the
time I'm assuming this child actually comes from
aegon II just because he sleeps around so much
they made so many jokes about it during episode
8. The reason why they would want to do something
like that is because they they want as few people
in the line of succession as possible because if
they found a bastard potentially somebody could
try to put him on the Iron Throne like Gendry was
legitimized by Daenerys so potentially now he
has a claim to the Iron Throne once bran dies
obviously bran probably gonna live for a really
long time though it seems like Lara strong is
talking to alicent about aegon's bastard then
the real big thing that's going on here too is
you see kingsguard seeming like they're fighting
other kingsguard if you remember during episode
8 Alison confused one of the kingsguard Eric
for his twin brother also named Eric between
an e and an a like they had the same name just
separated by one letter and she's like oh I'm
so sorry for confusing you for your brother
I think they'll pay that off in this episode
there'll be some twist with the brothers because
you see them walking in the crowd too in one of
them handing what seems like viserys's Crown to
team black it just generally the kingsguard's
loyalties are divided so the idea is that while
Team Green is trying to name aegon the second the
successor officially in King's Landing rhaenyra
in team black also named her the next queen of
of Westeros so you have two different people
wearing crowns a divided allegiance from the
kingsguard so some of the kingsguard wind up
supporting her and some of the other people
in the realm in the other half supporting Team
Green during episode 7 Criston Cole were marked
on something similar to this where he said the
kingsguard have never had to protect Prince from
other prince before and alicent yells at him no
you serve me you don't serve the king do what I
say not what the king says it was just meant to
set up the whole idea of the divided allegiance
of the kingsguard Lord beesbury during the small
council meeting just screaming about how they're
committing high treason by trying to pull off
this coup so to speak I think he's just bristling
because of what they're doing and why they're
doing it so quickly without bothering to have a
conversation with rhaenyra or anybody from Team
black this just looks like the gold cloaks the
city watch inside the current version of the great
set getting ready to name aegon to the Iron Throne
remember it's a lot easier to sway the allegiance
of the gold cloaks and it's a lot easier to become
a member of the gold cloaks like they don't have
to be celibate they get paid a little bit less so
the rules aren't quite as strict as they are
for actual kingsguard but remember Daemon is
the one who created the gold cloak so a lot of
their allegiance also lies with him and he is
firmly team black even when aegon the Conqueror
became king of Westeros and the crown was put on
his head it was actually the high septon of the
day that did it to perform the actual ceremony
so they have to do something similar with aegon
II like they had to get him to this version of
the great set that we saw in a previous episode
and have the current high septon place aegon's
crown on his head they also confirmed my theory
that somebody like literally grabs aegon II out
of bed just barely awake Kicking and Screaming
dragging him to be crowned like they're in the
great set here aegon II still seems like he has no
idea what's going on like why are you waking me up
so fast why are you dragging me across town and
they have to force him to put the crown on but he
wants nothing to do with it just like Jon Snow he
doesn't want it this is actually the commoners at
the dragon pit so obviously different shot totally
different Scene It just seems like they're going
crazy over the succession and obviously a big
point of contention is the dragons themselves
and that's one of the big things that Otto
Hightower is trying to prevent and rhaenyra
and her supporters from getting access to to their
dragons so one of the biggest things to remember
here is that even though Otto Hightower very
clearly playing The Game of Thrones and trying
to pull off this coup super fast alicent is kind
of watching all this happen thinking that she's
doing the right thing but not totally sure about
it like they want you to sympathize with her just
a little bit because she's not trying to get power
for herself like she doesn't actually want to be
on the Iron Throne herself the way that Rhys
Ifans talks about his character is also kind
of funny too he says he believes in his head
that he's doing the right thing for the realm
but secretly what's happening is he's really just
benefiting himself his own house we play an ugly
game and now for the first time I see that you
have the determination to win it it's one of those
situations where people do very terrible things
but keep telling themselves that they're trying
to uphold Justice the law do what is right on the
flip side of that you have rhaenyra though who's
very clearly breaking a lot of the rules like her
sons are bastards technically per the rules they
shouldn't be allowed to sit on the iron throne
even though her sons with Daemon are legitimate
technically there'd be no issue in aegon the third
or viserys II sitting on the Iron Throne the way
that Emma D'arcy talks about her character about
her older version of verniera is that there were
all these lessons that were taught to her like
you'll have to stop doing all these crazy things
once you actually become the heir and she says
that the message just kind of blew past her like
she didn't completely get the message then she
would have to stop certain behaviors like sleeping
with Harwin strong thus you get to a situation
where she believes that she's entitled to become
the heir because her father named her the air even
though she broke a bunch of the rules so it's one
of those situations where they want nobody to feel
like they're completely in the right like on both
both sides they're both just a little bit terrible
doing terrible things to each other and that's one
of the tragedies of the dance of the Dragons the
other important thing is what's going on with the
commoners in this big Riot that could potentially
be developing in King's Landing back in episode 4
Daemon was like you need to pay attention to
the commenters they made this big deal about
how the commoners actually didn't care about the
succession like there was this whole idea when she
was younger about her being named air but nobody
really respecting her the way that she wanted to
and Daemon showing her the play in flea bottom
was basically to let her know that the commoners
didn't care about any of that stuff the only thing
the actual commenters care about is stability they
don't actually care who their king or queen is
it could be anybody from any of the houses as
long as there is stability in the realm that's all
they want so the whole idea of Team Green versus
Team black and all the injustices that are dealt
between the families all the insults everything
the commoners don't care about any of that stuff
so while you have this big Civil War that's
brewing within their family also pay attention to
what's happening with the commoners and remember
there's a growing influence of the faith of the
seven that'll also probably become a bigger thing
in future Seasons during the main Series Game
of Thrones the highest Sparrow the high septon
of that day wound up becoming a big problem for
the crown we'll see if something similar winds up
happening in future Seasons but if you spotted any
other Easter eggs and references in the trailer
that I didn't talk about in the video just write
it below in the comments in my full episode nine
video will post next Sunday after they release
it while you wait for everything everyone click
here for my full episode 8 video and click
here for all my other house of the dragon
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!